sleeping around has made me miserable
too how did you change your dating
approach when I got a little bit older I
stopped going on dates that involved
alcohol because I realized that if I
drank I usually drank more if I didn't
like the person because the experience
was so painful that I was just numbing
myself with alcohol don't do that so
then when I was 22 I said okay I'm only
going on coffee dates and it's only for
half an hour so I'd meet up with someone
you can tell right away if you like
can't stand a person or if maybe they're
interesting so you have a coffee date
and then you decide to have another date
and then maybe that one involves alcohol